what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch our final set of
Ant-Man trailers I just dropped them all
in the Final Cut we're gonna watch before
experience an Emerald City John how are you I
am very much anticipating these spots you wasp
sounds racist change a couple letters there
anyway guys I want to give a quick mention
too by the way we're almost at full capacity
here if you haven't caught the memo yet John
can be a Christian harloff and I are doing a
live event at Flappers in Burbank California
Sunday February 19th at 9pm what inspired this
the weekend of Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
so we wanted to talk about that q a whatever
other hijinks might occur Christian Hall's
gonna be doing some stand-up comedy beforehand
if you are in the LA area or are visiting would
love for you to come attend yeah of course
love to talk to you after the show as well
but don't look campy in the eyes they'll
kick you uh let's get to it guys foreign
you're an interesting man Scotland you have a
daughter that's interesting you're an Avenger
you read my book nice I killed you before but
they just spoil that on February 17th I can
shattered existence nothing can prepare you you
may not want her to watch this for the new Dynasty
experience it in 3D February 17th Scotland you're
an Avenger wow wow you're out of your league
that's Power sword kind of shatter timelines
everything you call a life will end and you're
not getting out I think he will yeah man but
nice try we both just have to lose Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum media ready PG-13 February 17th
get tickets now a lot has changed about my life
we literally saved the world literally but
right now the only job I want is being a dad
Scotland do you want to get out cool so beautiful
and I need to get out of here what's that oh
I cannot trust him we'll see I don't care
who this guy is I just lost so much time
risk it all Scott who thinks he's
a God everything you call a life
this guy Cassie we'll stop him
together you think you can beat me
Ant-Man and a wasp quantumia rated PG-13
in theaters February 17 get tickets now
ah dope love excited love it can't wait to can't
wait to review this movie looks so exciting guys
there's a lot of good tidbits in here a lot of
good expansions on some other moments that we've
already seen prior I guess it was that one moment
where you know like I like that moment where he's
you know giant man form and he goes crying but
when he knocks over that building and the blue
smoke um disperses from there I was like wait
a minute is that like kings tower that they're
revealing he's just knocking over because why is
he specifically targeting that Tower yeah you know
yeah yeah yeah yeah cause I've been avoiding leaks
on this movie um I'm very very excited for I've
been reading a lot of Kane Comics as of late a lot
of my late nights before I go to bed it's been a
lot of King and so far I feel like from the little
glimpses that we've been getting you know Jonathan
majors has especially been embodying everything
about that I enjoy reading with Ken because he's
a very you know uh poetic type of individual and
thinks very highly of himself and I I like that
but he's also like a sad guy you know like deep
down underneath he's sad and there's a lot of big
hardened shell of a lot of pain and hurt where
a lot of this uh aggression and focus towards
depending on the run that you read but a lot
of the stuff that I've been reading at least
a lot of the the goal of conquering and stuff you
know like we've had ravona rentslayer be brought
into the Loki season 2 show and that is such an
integral part of King's life and I imagine that
if you're introducing he who remains within you
know uh Loki season two that yeah there has been
any hints towards her here but you know there are
certain runs where it a big part of the focus is
getting to rivona so I I feel like though might
they might bring it back to that because they
are emphasizing the dynasty angle here within
the the marketing so I'm I'm least curious to
see how it goes because yeah I mean the big talk
about this movie is King itself but what I really
also enjoyed about these spots in particular is
just the expansion of the the cosmic not even
caught I don't even call it the quantum battles
that you're going to be getting yeah the quantum
battles that you're getting here uh just look like
they're gonna be wild and I I didn't even really
quite go there when thinking of the the level of
Destruction and Chaos within the quantum realm
itself that we are going to be witnessing as this
film has probably some insane Crescendo that will
be perhaps Bleak and not as uh optimistic and
as I was getting these dark endings okay well I
mean you look at him here and like that one shot
of him like screaming where his face is like his
lips are like drained of color and he looks like
so just battle worn yeah like they're really gonna
throw him through the ringer in this movie and
two I mean even though what they're leading with
is mostly the spectacle and mostly the you know
wild nature of the quantum realm the mind-bending
nature I do Wonder because there isn't an aspect
of this that is you know Kang needs a McGuffin of
some sort uh I wonder a if they'll bring back
some of those Heist flavors that they uh you
know obviously that Mark the Ant-Man series but
also if I mean some people have speculated that
maybe here what it will be is that Kang doesn't
need like a piece apart it is maybe ravona that
he's going to try and you know secure to you
know help pop off his main plan or something
like that so like I don't know I feel like the
interconnectivity that we were craving for for
phase four is like primed to pop off in this place
because you have Loki season two coming probably
in the summer time and uh you know this like
chronopolis as they've realized it here has so
many just stylistic and aesthetic similarities
to like the TVA and things like that which was
you know spun by a different Kang and so yeah I
I feel like we could have more of that universe's
crossover than we're even expecting from this not
that I want like the Ant-Man movie has been kind
of great because they haven't focused too heavily
on crossover and a bunch of extra stuff coming in
um but you know they have said that this is going
to be like a very significant it seems like they
want this to be the most significant Ant-Man movie
so aside from all the personal stuff with Cassie
and everything thing like I I I'm getting the
sense with how scopic and huge these trailers
are that they probably will bleed into and feel
very consequential to the rest of the universe at
hand along with how you're like Bill Murray and
Modoc and like you know fun uh Side characters
to bring in and stuff like that and yeah like I
love the anger like the seething anger that reads
off of Kang the Conqueror here because he remains
does have like such a bubbly personality but you
can feel that sadness that pathos underneath and
here it seems like all that bubbliness has just
been replaced with a rage and I love the tones of
the performance they're putting here because yeah
he's talking so soft but when you really see him
he is like overflowing with anger and I feel like
that could create a really cool tension for that
character just as a performance yeah there's a
lot to grasp on to here people can't wait social
media reactions left on Tuesday let's see what
everyone has to say you know they're all going
to be [__] they always go even when a movie's
bad it's always [__] you can't buy I asked with
you free screenings yeah alrighty guys well leave
your thoughts down below and what you're most
looking forward to about Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania uh subscribe keep a look out for
our review last but not least I'll send us for the
Doran ah man I would love to go to the quantum
realm with you sir because no matter what the
threats would be you would have uh you know a
way to lift all of our Spirits I feel like you
would be the prime stand-in for an Ant-Man at the
reject Nation you're Plucky you're good-natured
maybe sometimes a little down on your luck or
whatever but you never let that get to you flev
and every time I see you you know even in text
form you just you just make me want to smile you
know you just bring me Good Vibes you were like
Good Vibes incarnate the person and uh and we know
you love Marvel and I bet you're excited I wish we
could bring you with us that's the ultimate goal
is one day we all need to watch a Marvel like a
fresh new Marvel movie in the theaters together
that's what I hope happens so uh you know however
whatever Time Heist DEH hijinks we need to do to
secure that let's make it happen flev let's do it
Flav coming to California and sit in front of us
and be on your phone all day yeah at the movie and
get us kicked out we'll talk with you soon buddy